the jurogan experience i was watching
that documentary on one of my flights
recently about the uh
the chinese exclusion act i've seen that
what's that
there was this whole act in the uh they
were showing about like the first
chinese guy that came to america and i
think it was in the uh
1700s he came over and then
he proved to be a good work and
eventually by the 1800s there was like
60 000 chinese people and then
for some reason america had a problem
with them and they
they had this exclusion act too um they
had even allowed black people to be free
and black people to vote but the chinese
were considered less than human
wow this was the 1800s so this one
1882 yeah is this when they were working
on the railroads then they let them come
in and work on the railroad but they
wouldn't allow them to become citizens
bro you ever see photos of chinese
people working on the railroads
they're some of the bleakest photos and
they all had their hair
back like their foreheads were huge for
me the way they would pull their hair
back
they probably didn't want their hair to
get stuck on the [ __ ] tracks that
sounds about right yeah yeah imagine
a train comes by and catches you by the
hair oh yeah they they uh
they use them pretty badly it's a
horrific story but the the photos we
were i was watching that uh hulu
uh docu-series sasquatch and uh it was
talking a lot about
you know like the people that they use
to
to make the railroads and to to
mine and the people that that used to uh
chop to cut down the trees up in the
pacific northwest and uh up in uh
northern california yeah with the yeah
there's these photos that they
they showed of these chinese folks that
were
working on those railroads and it's so
depressing man
yeah they were treated like [ __ ] and
there's just no hope you're not getting
out of that there's no upward mobility
there's no
there's no future yeah there's no
promise
yeah and then they weren't allowing them
to become u.s citizens even if they were
born here
you know what's crazy even today like in
harvard
it's more difficult for asian people to
get in than anybody else
really yeah there's a lawsuit about it
right now yeah
apparently they have so many asian folks
that uh were getting into harvard that
they decided to
specifically tailor their tests to make
it more difficult or their requirements
or what they
uh what they're what
see i don't want to [ __ ] this up because
uh andrew yang's people were the ones
who were
talking to me about it one of the guys
who came last time when andrew yang was
here
nice guy that andrea he's a great guy
yeah he's a great guy
i hope he runs again well he's going to
run for mayor
of um of new york city he's running
right now and it's him and this other
gentleman
who was
forget what he did but this other guy
carries a [ __ ] gun
and he's talking about like ramping up
police presence and
uh he's a black guy and a lot of people
are behind him
and they think like this is what we need
to turn the city around like they need
to respect
law and order right and they need to do
something about the [ __ ] crime
there's a shooting spree in times square
the other four-year-old got shot woman
and her daughter
that's crazy so here it is yeah
america's skills court rules harvard
doesn't discriminate against asian
american applicants oh okay so this is
federal appeals court in boston has
ruled harvard doesn't intentionally
discriminate against asian-american
applicants so what was the argument
because the there was a lot of asian
people that were insisting that that was
the case
said the statistical evidence did not
show that harvard intentionally
discriminated against
asian americans students for fair
admissions an advocacy
advocacy group first filed its lawsuit
in 2014
saying it's harvard that harvard's
race-based considerations for applicants
discriminated against asian
american students in process today's
decision once again
finds that harvard's admission policies
were consistent with supreme court's
precedent supreme court precedent and
lawfully inappropriately pursue
harvard's efforts to create a diverse
campus
that promotes learning and encourages
mutual respect and understanding our
community it's like what is the
argument though opponents were ending
race-based considerations
at u.s universities were unfazed by
thursday's decision to plan to bring the
case to the supreme court
so what does it say what is the question
okay the question of how much
race should be a factor in college
applications is a hotly contested one
president trump's administration has
challenged college on using race and
admission policies
claiming such practices violate federal
law last month the department of justice
filed a lawsuit
against yale university saying its
policies violate the civil rights act of
1964
yale has said the lawsuit is baseless
what is school's admissions rules though
that's what i'm confused with
well so does that mean uh external
chinese people or chinese americans
um i think i just think just asian
period
well when they do race they don't they
don't say well because we only want
african americans i mean i'm asian right
i mean
right so i mean right it's vague right
but i mean i can understand you're a
candidate you're canadian it cancels
everything out it's true
that's true uh what is the race-based
admission policy though that makes
them say that they discriminated what
does it say
see if you can find oh look they've
tried to pop up at you [ __ ]
see if you can find what the argument
is that harvard does discriminate
against asians
but these guys that were with andrew
yang they
believed pretty strongly that that's
what harvard was doing
i mean you know there's a lot of those
admissions tests that are race
racially biased according to how you
grew up and what you know
you know so i think what they tried to
do is make it
the person who wrote the test or
whatever wrote it from their perspective
we need to fix society so that you never
have to think about that [ __ ] at all
you know oh here it goes
in the lawsuit plaintiffs claim that
harvard imposes a soft racial quota
which keeps the number of asian
americans artificially low the low
percentage of asians
admitted to harvard plaintiffs
maintained was suspiciously similar year
after year despite
dramatic increases in the number of
asian american applicants
and the size of the asian american
population
during the lawsuit the plaintiffs gained
access to harvard's individualized
admission files from 2014 to 19
and aggregate data from 2000 to 2019 the
plaintiffs
also interviewed and deposed numerous
harvard officials from those sources the
plaintiffs revealed that harvard
emissions officers consistently rated
asian american applicants
as a group lower than others on traits
like positive personality likeability
courage wow kindness
and being widely respected what the [ __ ]
just think about what that says they
they
rate you on positive personality
like ability courage kindness
and being widely respected those are so
vague well i mean you know different
nationalities have different
personalities you know different races
have different ways of dealing with
things
what may be considered offensive to one
is not to the other you know or
likable to me is not likable to you for
sure but look at it says here asian
americans scored higher than applicants
of
any other racial or ethnic group group
on other admissions measures like test
scores
grades and extracurricular activities
but the student's personal rating
significantly dragged down their
admissions chances
wow that's weird man that's
i mean i guess you'd have to talk to
someone from harvard and get them drunk
and say what's really going on why do
you have this
likability courage kindness and being
wildly respected and what is a positive
personality
you have to be positive what if you're
like god damn it i suck but you work
really hard
like that's a negative personality but
yeah you know like you're
maybe you have a negative opinion of
yourself but you work really hard maybe
that's why you work hard because you
don't think of yourself very
it's weird man harvard's admissions
staff testified they did not believe
that different racial groups have better
personal qualities than others but
nevertheless asian applicants as a
racial group receive
consistently weaker personal scores over
the period surveyed and harvard
admissions officers rated asian
americans with the worst personal
qualities
of any racial group wow african
americans on the other hand
consistently scored the low the lowest
on academic rating but the highest on
the personal rating
but you know what personal rating that
like makes me think about
like that whole the the chinese social
score
system oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't
want that i don't like that
that's a very weird thing catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience